on that day
humanity received a grim reminder
that this scene has been parodied so
much that no one can take it seriously
anymore
the titans are gonna eat us because
we're cow but we have walls and there's
no way they can break through the front
door
probably oh god we gotta save mom aaron
put your back into it i have no fear i'm
here to save the time hands thank god
all right i need you to help
what the [ __ ] haunts my mom [ __ ] your
mom
oh god this is not what i thought when i
clicked this link
aaron how are you feeling from this day
i swear i'm gonna kill every last titan
but not before i dance in their grave
when i'm showering in the blood of all
the titans i massacre they will know the
name every last damn one down on their
[ __ ] demise
is he still going because my ticket
every titan will die in my head
shut the [ __ ] up
so
do you like titans oh my god
[ __ ] them all i will never submit we'll
come to military school all this
training will probably be useless
because 90 of you will die anyway side
characters introduce yourselves i'm an
internet meme i have a great ass when
it's titanic i'm going to be forgotten
i'm going to be alive
well i'm going to be an actual
interesting character shut up gene or
zhong come back when you're a main
character
hey hold on a second i have screen time
don't listen to him you're my main
character shut up marco come back when
you're not a disposable character
congratulations on graduating you are
now officially certified cannon fodder i
now have all the weapons i need to kill
the titans actually last time i checked
edge isn't actually a weapon don't
listen to her those stupid titans don't
send a chance against me
why don't you say that against my face
you little [ __ ]
the titans have invaded looks like we
get to fight titan i am slightly fretful
at the thought of fighting titan i
strongly disagree with your sentiment
there why are we all shouting i don't
know isn't this how we're supposed to
communicate in this show
what the [ __ ] everyone is dead except
for me cause i'm the mig
yeah your boyfriend brother is dead hey
he's not my boyfriend
yet gross do you even know why he means
so much to me here mikasa have this dumb
scarf oh my god i can't believe he gave
me a scarf it smells so good maybe if i
wear long enough he'll notice me and one
day we'll start dating and then get
married and have a bunch of kids
do you like it eh it's all right that's
right what's the point of living anymore
guys did you see that titan what do you
think it could possibly be aaron aaron
aaron probably aaron seriously who else
is it to be oh come on that's way too
often oh look it's actually aaron
[ __ ] you all you have exactly five
minutes to explain yourself before we
blow your brains out armin everyone
thinks i'm now a threat to humanity it's
up to you to convince them i trust
you'll know how to
don't show [ __ ]
maybe instead of killing our only hope
we should use them to plug up the wall
that's a great plan sir you should
probably tell everyone right now listen
up we are going to take back the wall
from the titans so hear this plan what
we're going to do
he does realize he's like 200 feet up
now right take the lines and turn it
upside down prince of bel-air style nope
he has absolutely no idea but that is
the black does anyone have any questions
all right did you catch all that get
aaron so triggered by his titan self
that he punches himself in the face yes
hey aaron guess what you're a titan
do it do it again oh wait we should
probably get him to carry the boulder
out of the way guys
uh where am i wait a minute you're the
survey scouting regiment scouting
leaking reconcore
yes and i'm captain levi
uh what was that ignore that so aaron
remember this key which opens your
basement that's going to be a huge plot
point now well do you mind telling us
what's in it yeah i remember my dad told
me before hey dad what's in our basement
ah sure thing son it's called gary the
[ __ ] manga god damn it every bloody
time all right in the trial of whether
or not we should execute aaron yeager
will both sides please state their cases
kill him don't [ __ ] kill him please
compelling arguments how does the wall
religion view this as a follower of the
wall it is our belief that any foreign
object will pose a great threat to us as
foretold long ago by our founder and
supreme prophet lord trump does the
defendant have anything to say okay
aaron you can get through this the best
way you know how the shouting really
loud solve my problems
captain aaron's enjoying it you're in
stop enjoying it
is this really how the fujiyoshi saw
this scene look enough of this i propose
that from now on that aaron will be
supervised by me privately at all times
oh god yes god damn it sustained under
the notion that all fangirls now think
you have this weird dominatrix thing
going on with each other now that that's
over allow me to introduce my crew dead
one dead two and petra i'm the only one
everyone cares about because i'm a cute
girl what about her titans make me horny
did i just hear that correctly yes no
enough of this survey chord head out but
first
we clean oh god seeing you clean makes
me so wet what what
[Music]
wait how long are we gonna be riding on
these horses oh about five episodes or
so what how have we gone from years
passing in a single episode to spending
half an arc on a [ __ ] horse what is
this arc even about that titan's got a
nice ass [ __ ] oh what the [ __ ] is that
don't worry aaron it's all part of
irwin's fail-safe plan it's all part of
erwin's fail-safe plan
mission
success
listen fail levi's squad get her
[Music]
oh no levi squad they're dead
petra now
nice punch jackass
oh my god aaron can you stop getting
eaten already jesus christ do i have to
do everything myself
well i don't know about you but i'd call
this mission a complete bus just another
day for the survey corps
my entire team is dead i know we're all
feeling a little bit down but we figured
out annie is the female titan even
though it was blindly obvious to
everyone watching even for blind people
and i have an absolutely foolproof plan
to lure her into a trap what's the plan
annie come with us please please please
no it didn't work god [ __ ] damn
aaron now would be a great time to get
angry that's my secret cap i'm always
angry oh
god it hurts so much
was something supposed to happen i don't
know it just sounded really cool in my
head let me give it another
shot and it hurts even more this time
aaron turn into a titan i'm trying okay
you're not trying hard enough what do
you want me to do oh god aaron just shut
up and get in the goddamn titans
is it just me or does this look like
very forceful titan sex god don't make
it weird armin all right annie i have
you just where i want you oh what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] that's that's
[ __ ] hacks well erwin in a few days
you've cast hundreds of lives years
worth of collateral damage and all you
could show for is a prisoner we can't
even touch now do you have anything to
say just another day for the survey
corps
[Applause]
why did you let my mom die you bastard
i'm sorry okay i only know my secret
technique of running away did you just
make a jojo's reference aaron what are
you talking about your mom just died
this is no time for a jojo's reference
there's always time for jojo's reference
all right okay
i was making a jojo's reference
oh my god
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] is going on hey guys hope
you enjoyed the episode thank you very
much this month to jared cattell gabe
brown why is gabriel so [ __ ] she ruined
the whole episode vincent mooney lao ken
and everyone else on patreon for
supporting me and helping to make this
video possible if you enjoyed this
episode then check out my other anime
and minutes that i've done and i'd also
like to thank all my cast members and my
editor for making this video as great as
it was and on time too i'm actually
going to be in japan next week but i
will have videos up in my absence so
until then i've been giggup and i'll see
you all next time